[Musik]
die truppe dir vor kurzem mit unserem
grill video bewundern konnte hat mich
gefragt wie eigentlich sollen schutz
genau funktioniert und ich hoffe sehr
dass das wetter angemessen ist wenn
dieses video online geht sonnenlicht
schuster schön sondern überlebenswichtig
aber zu viel uv-strahlung führt nicht
nur zu sonnenbrand und zu schnelle
hautalterung sondern ist auch die einzig
nachricht eine ursache für haupt- oder
zumindest die einzige ursache die wir
beeinflussen können neben sonnenhut oder
einfach mal drinnen bleiben sonst
sonnencreme vor uv-strahlung und zwar so
eine möglichkeit ist physikalisch schutz
durch mineralische nano-partikel die das
lokal zurück effektiv am meisten
verwendet werden nanopartikeln aus
titandioxid ein weißes pigment das unter
anderem leben wandfarbe zahnpasta und
kaugummis zu finden ist oder zinkoxid
einen anderen zweig das auch in einer
farbe aber unter anderem auf als
beschichtung von fotopapier zum einsatz
kommt eine zweite möglichkeit ist ein
schirmchen schuss durch sogenannte
aromatische molekül aromatisch nennt man
moleküle wenn sie so einen oder mehrere
ringe in ihrer struktur haben diese
moleküle können durch ihre aromatischen
ringe uv licht absorbieren sie nehmen es
auch und dann ist es sowohl zu den
nanopartikeln als auch zu den
organischen substanzen
diskussionen zu gesundheit und umwelt
die aber bisher strittig bleibt meine
persönliche einschätzung zu aktuellen
wissenschaftlichen lage ist schmiert
euch lieber gut ein
den hautkrebs ist coming vor ihm um sich
richtig einzucremen sollte man erst mal
den lichtschutzfaktor richtig versteht
dazu kann man sich klar machen wie diese
im labor bestimmt
hierzu werden menschen also probanden
mit einer künstlichen sonne lichtquelle
bestrahlt bis sich die haut der
mediziner sagt biss sich an eric kemen
wird und das macht man einmal mit und
einmal ohne sonnen kriegen der
lichtschutzfaktor ergibt sich jetzt
folgen damals er ist die zeit bis die
rettung auftritt mit sonnencreme detail
durch die zeit bis die rettung auftritt
ohne seien nicht uns faktor 15 bedeutet
also dass ich genau 15 mal länger in der
sonne bleiben kann als ohne sonnencreme
und mit genau meine ich ungefähr man
unterscheidet zwischen sechs
verschiedenen hauttypen wobei die
übergänge sicherlich fließen sind
jedenfalls allein die eigenschutzzeit
der verschiedenen haustypen kann sehr
stark variieren von zehn minuten alle
rothaarigen ca bis zu 90 minuten
der lichtschutzfaktor der auf der
flasche steht das ist nur ein
durchschnittswert außerdem sollte man
auch bei hohen lichtschutzfaktoren
vorsichtig sein
ab einem lichtschutzfaktor von 30 auf
jetzt kann man diese messungen im labor
an menschen gar nicht mehr so genau
durchführen
die bestrahlungszeit einfach zu lang
darüber hinaus treten uns anscheinend
nicht dick genug
sag ich doch laut dem deutschen institut
für normung bezieht sich die wirksamkeit
von nicht schutzfaktoren auf eine
sonnencreme dicke von 15 milligramm pro
quadratzentimeter haben in der praxis
das hat man untersucht drehen wir uns
nur mit etwa fünf milliarden sonnen pro
quadratzentimeter haut ein also was
lernen wir daraus
klickt euch oft genug ein empfohlen ist
so etwa jede halbe stunde
verlasst euch nicht auf zu hohe
schutzfaktoren und krebs
[Musik]
damit hoffe ich für euch und für mich
das heute wenn das video rauskommt ein
schöner sonniger tag ist den wir sowohl
genießen können als auch die tipps von
diesem video anwenden können auch wenn
ein sonniger tag heißt dass die user auf
youtube meist nicht so gut zurecht aber
umsatz zu komplizieren könnt ihr diese
zu teilen oder kommentieren wurde
abonnieren paar schätzelein er ist doch
erscheint hier sehen uns nächste woche
bis dahin bleibt sicher